♪ ♪ ♪
- Le Montana, l'État du grand
ciel. Une expression qui prend
toute sa signification.
Dans un coin de pays si
vierge.... Du moins en
apparenc d d d dans cette
immensité si silencieuse
se cache un des pires pollueurs
de la planète.
Et e, , , , il est presque
invisible. C'est le méthane,
qui s'échappe de ces puits
de gaz et de pétrole abandonnés
il y a parfois quelques
décennies.
Comme celuiù l'on voit
encore l'or noir qui bouillonne
non loin de la surface.
Ce qui grererere des
quantités astronomiques
de gaz à effet de serre.
Des puits comme celui-la,
il y en a plus de 3 millions
aux États-Unis.
♪ ♪ ♪
La solution se trouve
peut-être dans cette
petite ville du nord de
l'État, Shelby, à 40 minutes au
sud de la frontière canadienne.
C'est là que s'est installé
Curtis Shuck.
Celui qui a déjà travaillé dans
l'industrie pétrolière
s'est trouvé une mission :
il veut boucher tous les puits,
les uns après les autres.
Et il se déppopopopopour
en fermer 10 autres d'ici la fin
de la saison.
(démarrage)
Ainsi, il sillonne
l'État pour surveiller
et évaluer le niveau
de pollution généré par cesmills
orphelins et extrêmes pollueurs.
Une quête qu'il a entamée
il y a presque deux ans,
lorsqu'il a croisé ce tas
de bois et de ferraille.
Depuis, il s'entête à trouvers r
le problème de ces orphelins
pollueurs.
(bips sonores aigus)
Dans bien des États comme
le Montana, au fil du temps,rsrt
ralentie. Des puits de pétrole
ont vite fait de s'épuiser,
petit à petit et finalement
ont été abandonnés.
c c c c c c c quelques
travailleurs d'un secteur
en difficulté, Curtis Shuck
a assemblé une équipe pour
tente e e e e e e e problème.
Ici, ils enfoncent des conduites
jusqu'à près de 500 mètres
de profondeur afin de toucher
tstststststststs de pétrole.
Fermer un puits n'est pas
insurmontable, cela peut
se faire en deux jours et
le résultat est tangible.
Boucher un puits comme
celui-ci coûte environMaMaMaMaMe
une telle opération?
"La fondation Well Done, dit-il,
n'a pas accepté un seul dollar
des contribuables."
Et il gère l'organisme sans but
lucratif presque comme bénévole.
Alors qui paie la facture?
Dans le cas de ce puits
par exemple, la réponse
se trouve en fait à plusdedededn
où Fuyuki Fujiwara,
un gestionnaire de fonds
de placement de 52 ans,
a décidé de sortir son chéquier.
Il y a quelques semaines,l'l'l'k
a colmaté cet autre puits,
il n'y a plus d'émission
de méthane grâce à un autre
généreux donateur,a a a a a a a.
Au grand plaisir de Sam Stewart,
le fermier propriétaire de
cette parcelle, sur laquelle
se trouvent pas moins de
16 puits de pétrole abandonnés.
Tout profit pour lui, qui
n'a pas déboursé un seul dollar,
pour régler son prob
Mais
les particuliers qui participent
à ces fermetures de puits
pollueurs. En Pennsylvanie,
c'est la compagnie énergétique
a a a a a a a a a a a a financé
la fermeture de ce puits
il y a un mois, un puits
qui ne lui appartenait même pas.
Là aussi, le ciment qui déborde
est une bonne nouvelle pour
le propriétaire du terrain,l'lÉt
de la Pennsylvanie.
♪ ♪ ♪
Rédemption sur le tard pour
les uns, prise de conscience
environnementale pour
les autres, la solution à ces
millions de puits pollueurs
Curtis Shuck est réaliste,
il ne pourra pas y
arriver tout seul.
Il espère malgré tout fermer
un millier de puits
l'an prochain.
♪ ♪ ♪
Prochaine étape, la Loui
l'Oklahoma, avec des projets en
gestation au Canada et en
Amérique du Sud.
Curtis Shuck va continuer t t t,
créant même avec son équipe
grandissante une nouvelle
expertise dans le domaine
des mesures et de la détection.
Pour l'instant, une bonne
douzaine de puits
ont été colmatés.
Plus de trois millions
d'autres puits à fermer.
Un seul à la fois.